[Music]
so
do
[Music]
and uh covered and liz this will be
your last meeting with us will it
i believe i'm coming to the next uh
meeting and then jim's basement will be
that's correct okay thank you for that
right apologies we've got an apology
from
sarah lewis are there any other
apologies
appear appear to be none so
any conflicts of interest
appear to be none
uh
the current register of interest that's
pages seven to nine
uh i know there have been some
late late amendments to that okay you've
received duncan's have you yes i have
and i have updated it
yeah to move that we received
thanks kirsten seconded by
by duncan i'll put that all
as carried
out if you say no
um
the minutes are there any corrections to
the minutes
all right if someone prepared to move
the adoption of the minutes
recording in progress
um fell into the dead dying or diseased
category um or dangerous so they have
now been removed
and i believe i haven't been down there
to check today but i believe the last
truckload of logs
left site today of those so um we part
of the process was to
sell off those
what logs we could um that were
chopped down
so the contractor who chopped the trees
down um has act acted to sell them to
um there's uh someone who came through
the community um through paul and
another one of his contacts
um
so that's now being sold in the and the
money that um
was generated from that which wasn't a
heck of a lot about two and a half grand
um
has gone back in to the budget so to
speak so we just use that money to
offset the costs um of the project so um
the next stage in terms of those trees
is will get asplunded to actually prune
the ones that are
remaining there and make them safe and
get rid of any of the dead wood so that
that space will be
safe enough to open up to public use
um
whilst that work has been
um going um we've been in a bit of an uh
discovery phase i guess you would call
it
and in particular this area
um can you see my
mouse moving around yeah yep so
in particular this area um the arboretum
miner is of
not being used for reserve and therefore
being used to put all manner of things
from um hard fill to
old fence that's half covered in soil um
it is just everything under the sun in
in that space so
we are going to need to engage a
contractor to go in there and we've met
down there with a couple actually with
three now um
um obviously we don't want to deliver a
a reserve which it then has a whole lot
of ongoing maintenance issues around not
being able to mow or keep it tidy and
looking nice so um
unfortunately that that will have a cost
implication um
which is is reasonable but we think is
worth doing now um before we start
planting trees and things that we need
to get the land so that it's actually
feasible to allow people from the public
to go in and enjoy it and not be at risk
of rolling ankles and or
not not being able to maintain it so
um that's been a bit of a discovery we
knew we had budgeted for a small amount
of that but we hadn't anticipated quite
so much
um we've also
um in the background been looking a bit
into irrigation um you might recall we
had initially um
suggested that um
sorry
okay
we had initially suggested that the
trees could be watered by asplund as
part of their tree watering contract and
that we would extend that to a four year
period so they would just go and water
them individually
following
discussions um where we've i d
identified so with um jim and paul uh
and also with um a man called wolfgang
who um he looks after the christchurch
botanic gardens um so we've sought a bit
of um i guess specialist
knowledge from him on how these things
work best um and and yeah the advice
really is to do
a proper irrigation system um we have
water currently in the dog park um
about
uh we actually where that sort of tree
symbol is in the dog park um so it's not
too hard to continue that across and
um put in an irrigation system but that
obviously does um come with cot the
costs associated we're still working out
exactly what those costs are because
they are
quite determined on exactly what the
system is and
how we go about doing it
but they are significantly more than
what we were anticipating in terms of if
we were going to get a splunt to
do it but once again
if we're going to plant trees if we
especially if we're going to get the
community to donate and plant help plant
trees and and create this as a real
space that people feel ownership over as
a community we want to make sure that
we're putting the foundation and the
groundwork in right now um to be able to
ensure those trees really thrive so um
we see that is quite
imperial to to getting those trees um
doing well um
so that's um
just looking at my uh um
those those three things obviously have
have are gonna push the budget out in
terms of what we had estimated um
that being said
we've had a look back through the the
project and said well okay we where can
we try and cut some costs um what and
what is feasible clearance work and the
the irrigation the things that kind of
have to happen
up front because they
you can't plant the trees until the
irrigation is sorted out so and the land
underneath them is sorted out um so
one of the things i wanted to have a
discussion um with you around was
some of those ideas where we we have
identified where we can pull back so
obviously we have got a small amount of
contingency in there so um that that we
can use some of that um we
have got we had some professional fees
allocated into there which um
we are
trying to do as much of this in-house as
we can so that we don't have to pay
professional fees
um
however
um that's that's not going to cover the
the main the costs so my my
recommendation i guess to the board for
consideration is
currently
we have in the plan these these pathways
so we've got this main main pathway
heading across here and we have um
we were anticipating putting kind of a
gravel pathway in this normal um
northern area um my suggestion is at the
moment
um
the important thing my understanding is
is that we get some trees on the ground
we start getting them planted
a pathway can be added later
it may also be that once those trees are
planted and people start using the space
that we actually identify different
tracks that people are naturally going
and and so
one of my suggestion would be that
actually we we don't do the paths at the
moment we leave though obviously in the
master plan though that they're there as
a this is what we'd like to happen in
the future
but we use the budget that would have
gone towards
putting in those pathways uh which for
your information is about 60 000
what we need to use from that we use to
cover the costs of the irrigation the
ground prep and getting it right
what's left in there
we can then go and and identify okay
having this path here would be really
good and then we've got enough money to
do that
or it may be that we say but we'll come
back to the board and talk about you
talk to you about general landscaping
budget in the future or it could be um
in five years time it's an annual plan
um but um
that's kind of where that's sitting at
the moment um in terms of of that
project we're we're keen to proceed
because we this this winter's planting
season and and
um we've got
um
rotary and the store optimists are
really keen to be involved in that and
so we don't really want to stretch them
too far
but yeah that's kind of where we're
sitting um
i'll take question on that in a minute
but while i'm remembering the other
thing that
had been raised with the boards
or by the board previously was um an
idea that um
as we've got the lions have put in the
um
shelters in in the um dog park we've got
groceries or optimus putting in trees
um there's other community groups that
might be involved that this could create
be um i guess formalized as kind of a
community
um reserve um and that have that sort of
feeling to it um we've had put some
thought into how you do that whether i
think initially it got muted that we
could change it to change actually the
name to milton um
memorial community reserve or something
and that that elk um
what our thinking is possibly uh
one way we could do that if the board
was interested um was we could actually
just simply put signs at the entrances
um that say welcome to milton memorial
reserve many thanks to these community
groups who have contributed to making
this reserve that it is and listing
those those groups out that also gives
us the opportunity in the future if
another group comes and says hey we'd
really like to plant some trees or do
something we can just add them into that
list um but it helps the community who
are using it and
um come to to actually i guess
understand
the community work that's gone into it
it's not just something that the council
has
gone and done that it's actually been a
real community um driven project so
um
that obviously
we didn't have budget to be doing
putting signs
um
in
for
at the entrances but that is potentially
something you could consider
putting your general landscaping budget
to or something of the likes so
i've given you a few things to think
about in terms of milton um
more than happy to answer any questions
you guys might have
right think thank thanks grant for that
just come to you in a moment paul just
before we get to the questions i think
the name of the park has always been
milton memorial park so we wouldn't want
a reserve towards the water in
irrigation and signage if required i
mean we're quite capable
of
saying or doing something there when we
come to that that issue so just some
thoughts from me over to paul's i think
indicating
yeah um just a question on water
and
possibly
the north canary um model railway will
probably want water on their um premises
as well
and just in front of the
uh building we're going to go
and that's where the council water main
finishes
it's right there yeah so
would it not be more sensible to take
water from that area
is it
the 100 mil um
water main up to there where you've only
got the dog park i think it's either 20
mil or 25 mil so
and it's a long length of the year you
won't get much creature
um
coming from the dog park one because
it's a already a long length of um
pressure to that one and that's that's
um yeah that would certainly make sense
to go from that point
um in terms of the length from the of of
the pipe we probably
that wouldn't be wouldn't decrease the
um i guess the cost of doing the
irrigation but would certainly improve
the um
ability of it to to function and and
then so yeah no certainly we might get a
working together with the um railway
club um
for when they put water into this same
time possibly
potentially that that will obviously be
dependent on their
their club how they are progressing with
um their side of things i guess
obviously we
um we're on a if if we're going to plant
in this uh winter time uh winter
planting period we're kind of on a bit
of a
time frame in terms of getting that
irrigation in um but certainly we're
considering even just getting their
their water
connection sorted um now even if they
haven't got a building to actually
connect up to it so you know certainly
we can have um if there's economies of
scale we can have
to doing that together we'd certainly um
look at doing that yeah i don't know i
like all your ideas really good
right now
as i can't see you can you just say i
can see i can see kirsten and joan
uh say your name and ask your questions
i'll let other questions can i go jim of
course you can kirsten thank you um yeah
absolutely brilliant work grant i
totally agree about the paths they can
come later
you but the most important thing is to
get the below ground stuff done first
before you get the trees in obviously
because we don't want to put trees in
and then start digging up ground of any
sort so
i know you've got that all planned
just a question on the name i'm sorry
i'm not really really up with the
history either because i've only been in
the district 19 years um and i just i'd
love to see a report on the name just so
that it clarifies it for the whole board
in the community because i also feel in
this day and age we should also be
having a bilingual alternative um
because most of our parks are starting
to have a combination of the the two
national languages that we have here and
i just think that that should be
something we should consider um it's
something we should take into account
totally respecting the history but i
also would like to know um what the
staff think about how we should go about
formalizing the name of this park
whether we just keep it the same what
the recommendation is from staff if that
could be brought back to us as a report
i'd really like to see that
so that was my second point the third
point i totally agree with jim about
spending as much of our landscaping
money on this as possible get as many
trees in as possible
however i do also have a we
request i was going to make in that
second report to do with the dudley park
project for the youth council and i just
wanted to raise that
flag there a little bit that they are a
little short of budget
due to some of the costs rising
i i will um send me
keys and say yeah we we that won't get
lost don't worry um
yeah and in terms of a report on the
name
um we could certainly i'm not sure
whether that i i guess it's up to the
board what are your requests but um that
could be in the form of a official
report for decision or what we could do
is actually provide you with a memo on
how that name came to be and
other things around it then the board
can decide amongst yourself whether you
actually want to have something before
you for a decision or whether you're
happy with the status quo is it would
that be sufficient yeah that sounds
great okay i i think that covers it
because we we're we're not at that stage
yet i mean if it's raises milton
memorial reserve your your suggestions
grant of signage coming in recognizing
sir optimus lions and rotary or
community groups that contributed is
good
and that's that that's good so
yep right other questions
any other
questions
yeah just the wolfgang belly you spoke
to from the daniel gardens because he
did have any comment about planting in
up
which was great and and had a bit of a
wander around um
he he didn't wasn't worried that we
shouldn't plant there um but he
highlighted the fact that if if we're
doing this we should start now doing it
right rather than kind of
starting now because we're in a hurry to
get some trees and then going oh we
really should put some irrigation and in
the meantime half of them have died and
you say look plant it ahead now get your
ground right get your irrigation right
then put your trees in and then just let
it grow as as it grows rather than
getting too kind of
bogged down in the details of at the
start um
that's kind of the best way um he's also
um
providing some ongoing assistance with
us
around
ensuring tree selection and that he's
got a wealth of knowledge which is
awesome so um a resource we're tapping
into as much as we can so
yeah
i think what comes out of that grant is
we'd like to see the water laid pipes
laid and the trees planted
this weekend
any resurfacing or oversewing can be
done in the spring quite easily when
those things are done other questions
there's just one concern i just think
having a walkway across ash is um that's
not actually straight is it what the
hang the road is i always forget that on
this top on the stop bank having a
walkway across that busy
totally hear that and that's something
we
have we've been in discussions i guess
in the background with roading around um
and that's one advantage to be honest of
of us actually holding back a bit on
those paths as well um is that that
gives us an opportunity to see
works as the um
roading and cycling network grows and so
there's there's my understanding is
there's kind of a a planned work around
um
this area and and how circulation works
but that's we're kind of the head of the
ball game on that so
um
actually by holding off
it would be a shame for us to put a
pathway in and then for
that to actually look at and go well
actually the pathway would be safer and
better to go this way so um by holding
off it actually allows us to kind of
come back into the timing for how that
that whole network is working and do it
properly
um if we were to put
um
a crossing at that point on the stock
bank um that that would require some
level of work on um
milton ave tour people could like
we'd be looking at kind of um those
median um
barriers and things so that people could
cross there safely so we don't want to
kind of get into that side of things
until we know what roding's plan is
around that circulation network so
holding off kind of helps with that too
so everyone's happy with the pathways
being held off is there any objection
no that seems to be taken
for granted the other issue came up do
you want to touch on it now grant is
on the skateboard park and what's
happening there
yeah absolutely um so
the
um in terms of the skatepark um
you you'll be aware when it comes to
covert and any building projects at the
moment um
prices are just going through the roof
so
um we we've we have been working with
the um lions club who
quite generously offered to um work with
the youth council to help with the
construction of it so um
they they took our plans and have um
got up to to do it with them doing the
labor at a cheaper rate than what we
would be able to get um a commercial
person to do it as part of their giving
back to community
however
it's got come to the point where
just the the actual
material cost alone not including any of
their labor is virtually twice the
amount that we would normally expect to
pay for that size
one option which um we discussed was um
so when i say we i should say myself and
emily belton who is our youth
facilitator was that we could look to
the likes of general landscaping budget
for a bit of additional
funding towards that project to get that
deck across the line
however
we've actually um come to the conclusion
that we we it would be more prudent for
us to go back to the
um youth council and i've set up a
meeting to to to do this with them um to
go back to youth council and say hey
look this is the challenge we're in at
the moment the supply and the demand of
materials is a real struggle and that's
lifting the price up we need to look at
the priority of of these projects so you
might recall when they got that plan
five different projects on it
they had at the time they prioritized
building the deck and the picnic table
um
and so the other three were kind of low
on their priority lower on their
priority i should say sorry um and and
they they felt that they'd wait for that
and look for additional funding when it
came to that point and sort of do it in
a staged process
um our recommendation to them at the
moment is actually going to be look
let's re-look at the priority let's set
now we know the deck is kind of up here
um
let's let's look at whether some of the
other things can be lifted in priority
in the meantime until some of those
prices fit for timber in particular um
drop and and we can actually do that for
guests for for what we should be paying
for or would expect to pay for timber
and for decking so um there's a
discussion i'm going to have with the
youth council around that that
re-prioritizing so
i was going to come and have a chat to
you about that general landscaping
budget as an option but at this point i
think it'd be more prudent we have that
discussion with them if if they would
like to if they still say no we believe
the deck is the top priority we're going
to look for additional funding that's
the discussion we have at that point the
money we've got on these projects where
we're not paying absorbent fees um or
for
sorry um costs for materials um then we
wouldn't need to use access access that
funding so
hopefully that does that answer what you
were kind of thinking about kirsten
you think thanks grant um
my only concern is i'm not sure we're
going to see tim going down in price
anytime soon so i know that this project
was a very high priority for them so i'm
just a little concerned if you totally
understand that and and frankly we
we are looking
well i don't have a crystal ball but i'd
be surprised if they drop um a heck of a
lot in the next six to 12 months um but
they they did set this project these
projects and there was five or five of
them on there and they they just set
them knowing that there was going to be
a staged
process that was all required on on
funding so um i'm hopeful that with that
discussion with them we can kind of come
to a
best thing
otherwise as i said they might say no
the priority is dick um if that's the
case then we're gonna have to have a
serious conversation with them around
how they intend on funding that and and
what the implications of
accessing community funds to do that are
um so obviously whenever we get funds to
do a project with
we're in essence taking that opportunity
from a different group so we need to
they need to make sure that that this
project that they're trying to get funds
for is something that they really
believe is
worth doing now and couldn't be put off
by a year if that makes sense so that's
a discussion emily and i
really need to have with the youth
council before we start talking to the
board or other areas around
additional funding for that project
question for me um originally wasn't the
youth council um when they started this
idea that i was going to apply for
funding from elsewhere for example
lottery um lotto and all those type of
things if they actually explore that
avenue
yeah so so that is still there in temple
um they i i guess this came up as a
um
because the amount that the pricing for
the deck came in and the money that i've
got at the moment um there was a
a moment i guess of well
to get the deck across the line we could
you you have enough in the general
landscape that you could pay that and
probably get it across the line um so
that's where that idea has come from but
um
i think they need to look at priority
they also then need to look at okay if
if they're saying the deck is a priority
they need to be looking at funding
they may come to the general landscaping
for that um but they also do need as you
say they need to be looking at other
other sources such as um lotto or
whatever sources that they see fit um we
we have um people in our community who
like rachel who are great at advising on
where they would be best to get that
from so um
that i guess that's why i'm saying
before we worry about trying to allocate
community board um general ads escaping
budget to this project there's a few
steps that need to happen and they
include
looking seriously at the prioritization
probably getting a
more idea on the the exact cost um and
also looking at other opportunities if
they want if they are really keen on
their priority
i i guess grant sorry might just about
and again i
the mayor and i are very concerned about
how long this has taken that 20 000
dragged on and on and on and for to keep
the youth council going they've got to
see something on the ground for that
project rather than just a piece of
paper so i know coverts got in the way
but um the price increase is not of
their doing it's actually how it is and
i would have thought that the board
would consider supporting that um so if
we spend all the money now that could be
a real concern before you've talked to
the youth council so i guess we're in a
bit of a chicken and egg situation i
wouldn't like to see all our money
committed until we know the results of
that conversation
we're quite safe there kirsten uh
even with the commitments to milton and
if we add more for water we're only a
couple of months away from the next
council allocation of
how much a year did we get okay
about 23 000 i believe 23 000 so the
board's got the youth council in the
back of their minds cursing so i
wouldn't be too concerned that's good
jim i'm sorry it's just it's it's a
summer autumn project as soon as we hit
winter we're we're delayed another four
or five months so it's just a concern of
that that both the mayor and i had
that's why grant you're going to see
that the board gets together
when it can
that correct and as in the youth council
yeah yeah yeah so we have got i've got a
meeting with the
um
i guess the subcommittee of that council
who's been dealing with this project i
believe it's next tuesday
um evening so um yeah that will we'll
have that talk through um
yeah i i totally it is it is a shame um
and you totally understand it's not it's
not their fault um it's a yeah it's a
real tricky situation because it's kind
of not their fault it's also not the
contractors or the suppliers fault it's
just that's how things are at the moment
building anything with timber is just
ludicrously expensive um so that they as
i said in their priority if they decide
that actually it's it's worth making
that and doing that um that's that
creates one discussion if if they say no
actually we'd prefer to do the picnic
table and maybe the
um
volleyball net um then that's something
that we can we can actually
do
um within and get it get the ball
rolling so it's just a discussion we
have to have with it but yeah
right any other questions
is there any chance of sponsorship you
know there are timber mills around the
place or mcculpins etc have they
considered asking
if someone might sponsor you know
provide the timber or whatever bits and
pieces are needed has that been
considered or not um so i understand um
the lions
um
they have talked um as sweetly as they
can
to the timber merchants to try and get
as best price they can but i mean to be
honest
timber is just one of those resources at
the moment that builders are struggling
to get hold of and so
it it's a struggle for any merchants to
um it's one of those things that
it it would be hard to convince the
merchants to um decrease the price or or
or give give timber away at the moment
because it's such a scarce resource
um
so yeah it's it's a it's just a a really
hard time to build a deck unfortunately
um
all right further questions
prepare to be none so grant for that but
thank you very much for for that and now
we'll move on to
item 7.1
uh
pages 18 to 24 and again that's you
grant
it is so um
we're once again here to uh talk to you
about general landscaping um
with the general landscaping budget that
budget allocated to some projects um
we ran a workshop with the boards and
identified four projects um that the
board wanted um
more information on um
around the costings so you could
consider it so
i'm going to take the report as read um
the pre the projects that uh within it
obviously are the um two at custom so
one is a rugby post um just that's so
standard h posts but just one
for kicking ball practice as opposed to
two that you would use for a game um
it's eight within custom main seats as
part of the rangora end of the
passchendaele um walkway um just as a
note to that i think it's in the report
but we've got a report going to the next
clipboard to a kiwi community board um
with virtually the same writing in it
just the the name switched around so
asking them if they would like to
contribute towards a seat at the end of
the walkway
um
and finally the town seat within the
townsend fields area um
grand total of all those projects would
be
10 700 um which
leaves about 16 000 in
the budget there additional allocation
which the board may choose to put
towards what milton or or to hold on to
projects or
whichever so
um hopefully um there aren't too many
curly questions in there around there
i've tried to cover off um things but um
you're more than happy to discuss or
answer any questions you have thanks
grant any questions
yeah one from me yeah
um regards the um the seating um
microcarpa um seating um
a supplier for that
i know logan sawmills they specialize in
microcarpa have we um suggested trying
them for the timber and maybe having
likes if the mint shed would like to um
knock the seats together
we looked at that
yeah so in terms of the
um the passchendaele seat we
the um
rsa have already indicated that they've
actually got the got timber um
donated from from one of them or for us
from a source so um that would just be
actually putting it together and they
they are keen to work with
um the
men's shed um on doing that um
i believe their thinking was that get
their talk to the ring euro men's
about doing the one and rang your and
the kai we mentioned about the one in
kai kaipoi um
yeah that's certainly a discussion we've
been having um with that um
in terms i mean that's certainly
something that that we could look at for
the cust um domain seat
seat um
i i would hesitate to say that it will
um dramatically i would sorry it will it
would reduce the cost if we got the
materials donated if the materials
aren't donated i'd hesitate to say it
would reduce the cost significantly just
based on
we did a similar exercise uh last year
in oxford um with the oxford men's shed
and they did a stellar job building us a
seat um and it's all installed but it it
didn't present great cost savings um but
it was a great opportunity to work with
that community group and get something
on into our street so um
but yeah certainly if we can get um
get that kind of thing um donated then
i actually wasn't actually thinking of
getting the number donated but i would
like to see using a supplier
rather than an external supply that's
tightening district yes sorry
prices yeah yeah so um in terms of those
seats um that the they're actually um
built um by wooden steel um which is a
tour here we based
um
that um dave
i can't remember that surname sorry but
um yeah my understanding is that yeah
that local company that uses local
things like that where possible so yeah
certainly that um that that's one of the
reasons why we do use those seats
because they're we do like using local
where we can yeah so i got the wrong
gist of where you were going there paul
you know i just
yet local that's all yeah certainly
any any other questions yeah
many
just the states one is it possible to
have arm rest on them to make them more
accessible for some people so they can
maybe older people and also can they be
positioned beside a footpath so let's
see i just wonder if that's an option
yep uh so
um certainly
an option for um where we can get so so
davis uh steel and timber
worker so um
my understanding is he has put arm rests
um
on those seats before and so we can
certainly have a have a chat to him
about doing that with with these
the seat within custom main the location
of it there isn't a pathway anywhere
near that area so
not with that one uh the seat within
towns and fields um
is
um
is kind of close to a path um
we potentially could
do it a short
so so i guess where it's
you're sitting on the seat looking
out towards the wetland and the path
would be behind you so to get a path to
the front of the seat we'd have to do
a bit of a shingle path
we could do that you'd probably be
looking
we did a similar thing in pegasus which
i think was about an additional thousand
um so you you could um we could look
into it obviously they've got to dig it
out and bring all the shingles and stuff
back in um
yeah there's certainly an option
passchendaele we would anticipate that
that would um be a along the path so you
would have access to that one
i just like whether the
access group might want to have some
uh contribution with regards to where
you position those seats just you know
that's accessibility is
a big part
yeah it's fair to say we're
where possible and practical we do do
our best to to ensure seats like that
are on a hard stand or or if the nearer
path you can get from the path without
having to traverse grass and things
because
yeah having a seated seat in the middle
of grass is like putting a seat on an
island for someone in a wheelchair in
the winter so
um
obviously we're practical we do we do
try to do that yeah absolutely
further questions
right repair appear to be none we have a
recommendation in front in front of in
front of us
i i'm prepared to move
just test it out
a b c a through to j
with a new k
and the new k would read
approve further allocation as required
for milton reserve
for
naming signs and irrigation any
remaining budget be carried over to the
22-23 financial year
have we got a seconder for that
[Music]
just to keep it
more open as to what the carryover could
be
uh because we've had
several suggestions of where we might
need to put more more funding
uh the youth council for example in
there it meets the
the the naming signs
the question and the irrigation question
and then it just carries it over and
it's very hard to say when you're
looking at town entrances and i've taken
the night the town entrance bit out
because the next town entrance the board
would be looking at is kippenberger
and from the last uh enquiries i've made
no one is sure
in what form or when kippenberger and
the councillors may correct me if i'm a
wee bit behind
um
is that because
no decision has been made that i'm aware
of by main power as to whether they were
um
put the power lines underground or not
and that then leaves the question of the
existing trees where they come out
whether they're suitable or not suitable
so that's not going to happen in the
next 12 months and the next board period
so that's why i changed the
the recommendation that i'm putting
about the town entrances they're still
there they're still a priority for the
board but it just leaves us more
flexible i think
as i said you've got
you you've got the
the youth council and other things we
might want to do
right any
paul do you wish to speak no i think you
said it all but wonderful one situation
any any other board member uh i think
it's flexible we'll remain in the
funding open and i think obviously we
talked a lot about irrigation tonight
and
grant i thank you for all your work
you've done on this but you know i
suppose we've always high access park
the world will see this uh it's got to
be a
a complete um
good job first up and i think we're
showing that we are looking at the
issues of soil types what's under the
ground and the access to water and water
is critical
and we won't be fortunate to have a nice
moist summer like we've had this one
next year i can tell you
so i hope you've got to be well prepared
for
to hit the ground running on this one
thanks duncan anyone else
all right i'll put the recommendations
all those in favor please say hi
i got the show yes show or yeah
thank you i declare it carried
item 7.2
the discretionary grant fund pages 25 to
39 okay
good evening everyone nice to see you
all again we haven't uh
i don't seem to have been able to have
seen you for ages so
good to see all your happy faces
um
in regards to the south brook netball
club
this is a group that have come to us
last year
in connection with
higher storage costs and
a hall for their prize giving obviously
it's only the beginning of the season
now
so the prize giving will only happen
um as i mentioned in the report that
if we still have restrictions that time
they do have a contingency plan
that they would split the club and do
juniors in one
celebration and the seniors in another
to make sure that they fall
neatly into the restricted areas
other than that they look for player of
the day trophies which if i'm sure you
with children and grandchildren
know how important those awards are
for people that um
either do any type of physical
activities it's
i just had my granddaughter get daughter
all day the other day and she was very
chuffed
um but i'll take the reporter's read and
answer any questions
questions
appear to be none that someone prepared
to i move i know they're asking for 500
and
two dollars thirty
someone prepared to move
monique
what are you moving
you look lovely but i can't hear you
you're muted you're muted monique
monique you mute
we can't hear you monique
sorry i was busy trying to unmute myself
well is it okay to do the 512 or just do
the 500 i mean if they want 500 12 30
it is in order to move the light if you
want to
i think 512
do you wish to speak
no i think all those in favor please say
i the country carried item 7.3
the
community board plan pages 40 to 59
okay that's you again
yes this is just updating your community
plan for the last
couple of months of this term
um
the changes i've made you've noted will
be in red
um i have received um subsequently
another change from duncan on
um on his
contact details and such like
apologies for any of the formatting that
is a bit out because
of the conversion from a publishing
package to word it sometimes throws that
out but it will all be fixed when it
gets put back into publishing
um i'll take the report as read happy to
answer any questions or put in any
further additions
are there any questions
jim just thought it was really good
there's just one place where waimakariri
is spelt wrong
in the report so just wondering if it
will get a final proof read
yep
well read and and uh okay you got the
changes for mine was i yes that's
correct duncan's right
no question someone prepared to move
that
know that moved by duncan seconded by
paul do you wish to speak
no i think it clearly outlines what what
about no good goals thank you
no
i'll put that all those in favor please
say hi
[Music]
there is no correspondence the cheers
report
on page 60 i'll move it duncan seconds
it
all those in favor free say aye contrary
carried item 10.
0.1
right through to 10.12
someone prepared to move receive
information
moved by duncan secondly
joan
i'll put that all those in favor please
say hi
the contrary it's clear it carried
members exchange well i'll go the
agenda i'll start with duncan
uh well just briefly i've been working
with staff members council regarding
some safety improvements outside the
lobbying reserve
um and secondly i had had a number of
inmate players generally and it's quite
a while since i've had contact with the
wider rate payers but obviously you know
roading issues are one that's come up to
the forward um and clearly they're quite
concerned about what is happening to
their roads um
that are the main items at the moment
thank you and it's a bit of a you can't
get out too often to meet the people now
it's uh been curtailed with um thank you
not a lot for me we're back zooming
again um which makes meetings a bit
shorter and a bit stranger um
yeah so
three waters obviously is still out
there local government reform we're
getting more briefings about that but
not a lot to report as yet
um
and
yeah we're just kind of treading water
to see what happens with the legislation
going forward for the year um district
plans progressing along they're working
on getting the panel up and running we
had a couple of late submissions but
nothing really critical um so that's all
under control and
yeah just then all of a sudden elections
are going to be
around the corner so everyone's starting
to think about that
thank you kirsten robbie
robbie
you're muted
can you unmute rob
i can't hear you
i think he's saying that he can't unmute
his so there we go i went to advanced
phone yeah um no just uh
very briefly i raised it at unr
it's just with regard to
the collections
um we mentioned
about three weeks ago that they
anticipated that if they had a drop-off
in drivers that collections potentially
could be
affected and also they've had issues
around sourcing parts for some of their
trucks
with delays and shipping
so if that occurs then
you know they will catch up but um it
may not be going as smooth and i am
aware of a couple of
even broken down last week
that's all from me thanks
yeah well hi i'm pleased to report that
um
all the culverts that i recorded on it
actually or they haven't been repaired
but the council's been over there and
put
uh
invisible stakes on the end of them so
people won't drive off to them it
appears that
the people that put the multimedia
cabling in over there to actually cause
all the problems
the other thing i've done is
i've sent an email to dan through
secretary this morning
and i won't get a reply till tomorrow
but i'm still trying to find out what
cdhp is doing about pulling the old
hospital there nothing seems to be
happening really
and
some of the gps that are due to go up
there are a bit concerned about it
and the only other thing is that i've
had quite a few complaints about the
potholes around the town i mean there's
a humongous one in
durham street for a start right outside
the canvas i noticed and nothing seems
to have ever been done about that
so i don't know whether anybody's
bothering to walk around the town and
look at these things and behind the
butcher shop and the fish and chip shop
in the car park the parking not only on
the
yellow lines but across the yellow lines
along the footpath
and a lot of the people who are disabled
and uh
in any way in the form are having a lot
of trouble getting around there because
the footpaths generally blocked all the
time
so it would pay for somebody to have a
look at that some cage and see what's
going on
thank you murray have you filled in or
put in a
notification of that pothole on durham
street not here yeah okay only thought
today yeah oh good thank you
get my car out of it but i'm sorry
monique
um i can do a snapseed wholesale on your
potpourri on durham street i'm quite
good at those and it seems to work very
well um i was at the hospital today
weeding the gardens got a bit out of
control they had it was quite a low
between the maintenance fellas changing
so but you know the hospital is being
demolished at the moment got no roof in
this
yeah
um thinking about that
that's all for me
thanks monique jason
um yeah just being part of north
canterbury neighborhood support who's
doing a wee bit of resilient just keep
an eye out
that's you
thanks jason uh morris
[Music]
on the ranger hospital first i actually
thought considering i was born there
there should have been a prediction law
to put on there
i got involved in
a flooding issue at the top of mount
thomas road
and i met with kelly simpson and dan
lewis
and we've
sadly
the problem is
occurred by two
um
awkward people probably politely putting
it but to travel up and down this
driveway to get into their properties
um
and so hopefully they've got to go to
egain to try and get it sorted kelly was
going to do that but i actually videoed
it on my phone and i'll show you at our
next meeting we can actually sit with
one another um but it's quite an
embarrassment it's been going on for
possibly 15 years
and nothing has been done about it
um so time will tell but i hope you
that's all thank you thank you morris
and well done on that sarah's
unfortunately as you know she's in bed
with covert she's been pretty sick to be
quite honest from what i understand
joan
well we've been busy on zoom um i just
have to say of course you'll all know
that the annual plan is out for public
consultation
at the moment for the next month
um
[Music]
we've had a few tender openings a lot of
people are under pressure with shortage
of staff and shortage of um
uh
supplies so that's affecting our tenders
but um
we're keeping on with that um
we uh
i've been involved with the bank of new
zealand divestments meetings with
um
and there are joints um promotions
meetings have um haven't been
progressing very well because we've got
nothing to write because everything's
been cancelled
um and um
ecan has presented us with their annual
plan so that's out for consultation at
the moment
and we had a meeting some advisory field
advisory um committee had a meeting with
a new consultant that
we have on board say with getting things
organized for us sorry about my duck
um and and that's me thank you
thank you joan andy
good evening everybody
uh paul and i are going for a drive with
cal to look at our roads on the 21st of
march so that's very exciting
uh and i think that's about
it
okay yeah can i just interrupt could i
please interrupt
my duck my duck
was a text from dan
saying number 32 upper hat has just
joined
they um
joined our phone
this is not public information oh sorry
i was all excited
yeah i'm looking quite busy um
i've been attending quite a lot of
flooding um situations in the area
lately and um some of the um
um
drainage
andy said about um how we trip on the
21st of march and unfollowing as per
council protocol behind
andy and myself we'll be going in my
vehicle so
actually three of us won't be together
because we're not allowed to be but um
how are we allowed to follow his vehicle
and um we'll check out some of the
gravel roads um because they are in a
the feedback we're getting there in
quite a bad state um i talked to go in
this morning about them and um trying to
get her to um do a bit of a presentation
for the community boards on what
recording in progress
but um
uh hopefully the government might start
um being a bit more sensible about it
it was on the news tonight uh it looks
like they're going ahead with a slightly
changed but not very changed format by
the look of it don't get new to question
paul can i ask the question and
normally the board probably wouldn't
drove quite into this detail but my
understanding from your comments at the
last meeting
when we raised the issues of roading
um
the comment was that you felt that
perhaps
the contractors and knowledge that
perhaps they had enough money and there
was an issue about how they did it and
those sorts of things did i hear you
correctly or have you sort of looked
into how efficient the whole operation
is actually running
um but basically looking into the whole
situation originally for the grading and
all that grammar i asked at the um
budget round whether there'd be more
money for
remitting the roads and the answer was
they've got significant um enough budget
to cover there
but since
i've been probing that information more
into the um
eroding team i've actually done a
uh they've actually commissioned the
person to go around and look at some of
the gravel roads and they're not
probably as good as what they originally
thought
and um which is uh
means that to actually fix them it's
probably going to be an extra budget
related scenario
um a lot of it there is just um
still you know better grading and what
have you but
some of the actual um
services has actually washed away every
time we have a web going into the drains
and the salts going away from the road
and it's just getting worse and worse so
it's
the difference between last month and
this month is i've done a bit more
investigating because um
um andy and myself have been leading a
bit of a charge trying to
resolve some of the um gravel roads and
and use this a breakdown on some of the
systems and um
and you know maybe the maintenance
hadn't been kept up
long enough because of the wet weather
so um i'm trying to organize joey in to
come and give a wee bit of a breville
roads around the area and you've got
some wonderful
photos that um picks up um
some of the condition of the road and
and how that they've got to that stage
so um we can't always blame the
contractors not keeping up
um so there's a bit of
a bit of weather involved in this a week
but i believe in contractors as well so
it's a a two-pronged attack but um
and we're working on it um as best we
can the
staff are under tremendous pressure at
the moment on
on other things as well so it's um
it's hard for them
you know to get the everything going i
think carl is on the same page as us and
um and
jared and joanne
is the same scenario so um
just a matter of a wee bit um
waiting and um and andy is my trip we'll
we'll go around and highlight a few
other
areas around the place and um we'll wait
for joanne to give a bit of a report to
us on it
thank you very much thank you thank
thanks paul
right item 12 is for your information
item 13 is for your information
there's no media items there are no
questions there's no urgent general
business but before we close i just want
to mention
two things the council's annual plan i
think kaye you've set down a date that
we might have to do it by zoom but the
board will meet and discuss that
um yes us to have the meeting earlier
than we knew and i discussed it earlier
jim okay whenever the board wants it and
suits you
so we we're hoping that the board can
maybe um accommodate us
either next week
um
which would be the week of the 17th if
possible
uh the week of the 14th if possible
so
if you're wanting to keep a wednesday
that would be the 16th
does that suit everybody wednesday the
16th
for the annual plan
council as you are excused if you wish
to be
um
um we will be discussing both the uh wdc
and the ecan one at that meeting right
um
so
yeah what time were you thinking of
that's up to the board
what does that say
is 16 5 30.
i'm seeing everybody nodding or putting
their fingers up so
yeah and
you'll send a reminder out i will do
oh and it'll be a zoomed number yeah
hopefully
okay the other thing you mentioned the
okay was the
ecan annual plan for those of
the highlights of it is it affects us as
i see it
the bus fare structure that they're
recommending some
major changes in the bus sphere
structure one whether they have free
buses or a flat two dollar rate
or
the current service and of course they
have quite substantial rate
implications for us if we
move away from the current service
and just for you your your consideration
they've they're talking about flood
recovery
and future funding for climate change
the overall average rate increase those
who don't know is 24.1
that if you couple on last year's who
can remember what they were last year
but it was well in the 20s
that's close to somewhere up towards 50
percent for
a
retired person or someone on low income
and two years from he can i hmm i think
they cut it back to 18 jim
it's just a big deal
exciting yeah okay so we can deal with
that at the same at the same time then
the board chairs had a meeting the other
day which we were going to discuss with
you
uh which we notified with dan
and we don't normally submit as a board
to he can in other words get heard we
submit last year i think we supported
the count our plan and
maybe you might like to consider when we
meet whether we
just support
providing the council's touching on the
issues we are we support the council
because uh
council we've went with all the board's
support of its uh
our submission might be just as strong
if not stronger than the boards putting
in written ones which tend to get
ignored just just a thought for you to
think about till we till we meet on the
16th
all right
so jim just a question on that what get
ignored
well the board
firstly the board normally only puts it
in in writing
uh i i i don't think the board's ever
asked to be heard that i i'm aware of
someone can correct me on that
and the council's one which we joined
last time i was told afterwards
by an econ councillor who you probably
know very well uh said it had more
impact when the district came with the
board support to the council that's why
we
the board chairs were talking about it
like that okay that's nice to know
because i didn't know that information
no no no
we're totally open-minded on it sure i
mean obviously if the board agrees with
the council submission
oh well of cour of course
[Laughter]
naturally all right
so so look
okay i'll need to